[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hi i'm cassandra clare and i'm going to
be reading chapter 8 of neil gaiman's
coraline
the other mother looked healthier than
before there was a little blush to her
cheeks
and her hair was wriggling like lazy
snakes on a warm day
her black button eyes seemed as if they
had been freshly polished
she had pushed through the mirror as if
she were walking through nothing more
solid than water
and it stared down at coral line then
she had opened the door with a little
silver key
she picked coraline up just as
coraline's real mother had
and coraline was much younger cradling
the half-sleeping child
as if she were a baby the other mother
carried coraline into the kitchen
and put her down very gently on the
countertop
coraline struggled to wake herself up
conscious only for the moment
of having cuddled and loved and wanting
more of it
than realizing where she was and who she
was with
there my sweet coraline said her other
mother i came and fetched you out of the
cupboard
you needed to be taught a lesson but we
temper justice with mercy here
we love the sinner and we hate the sin
now if you'll be a good child
who loves her mother be compliant and
fair spoken
you and i shall understand each other
perfectly and we shall love each other
perfectly as well
coraline splat scratched the sleep grit
from her eyes
coraline scratched the sleep grit from
her eyes there were other children in
there she said
old ones from a long time ago were there
said the other mother
she was bustling between the pans and
the fridge bringing out eggs and cheeses
butter and a slab of sliced pink bacon
yes it coraline there were i think
you're planning to turn me into one of
them
a dead shell her other mother smiled
gently
with one hand she cracked the eggs into
a bowl with the other
she whisked them and whirled them then
she dropped a pad of butter into a
frying pan where it hissed and fizzled
and spun
as she sliced thin slices of cheese
she poured the melted butter and the
cheese into the egg mixture and whisked
it some more
now i think you're being silly dear said
the other mother i love you i will
always love you
nobody sensible believes in ghosts
anyway that's because they're all such
liars
smell the lovely breakfast i'm making
for you she poured the yellow mixture
into the pan
cheese omelet your favorite coraline's
mouth watered
you like games she said that's what i've
been told
the other mother's black eyes flashed
everybody likes games was all she said
yesterday she climbed down from the
counter inside of the table
the bacon was sizzling and spitting
under the grill it smelled wonderful
wouldn't you be happier if you won me
fair and square asked squarely
possibly said the other mother she had a
show of unconcernedness
but her fingers twitched and drummed and
she licked her lips with her scarlet
tongue
what exactly are you offering me said
coraline
and she gripped her knees under the
table to stop them from shaking
if i lose i'll stay here with you
forever and i'll let you love me i'll be
your most beautiful daughter
i'll eat your food and play happy
families and i'll let you sew the
buttons back into my eyes
her other mother stared at her black
buttons on blinking that sounds very
fine she said
and if you do not lose then you let me
go you let everyone go my real father
and mother the dead children
everyone you've trapped here
the other mother took the bacon from
under the grill and put it on a plate
then she slipped the cheese helmet from
the pan onto the plate flipping it as
she did so
letting it fold itself into a perfect
omelette shape she placed the breakfast
plate in front of coral line
along with a glass of freshly squeezed
orange juice and a mug of frothy hot
chocolate
yes she said i think i like this game
but what kind of game shall it be a
riddle game
a test of knowledge or skill an
exploring game suggested coraline
a finding things game and what is it you
think you should be finding in this hide
and go seek game corlyn jones
coraline hesitated then my parents said
coraline and all the souls of the
children behind the mirror
the other mother smiled at this
triumphantly and coraline wondered if
she had made the right choice
still it was too late to change her mind
now
a deal said the other mother now eat up
your breakfast my sweet don't worry
it won't hurt you coraline stared at the
breakfast hating herself for giving in
so easily but she was starving
how do i know you'll keep your word
asked coraline
i swear it said the other mother i swear
it on my own mother's grave
did she have a grave asked coraline oh
yes at the other mother i put her in
there myself and when i found her trying
to crawl out i put her back
swear on something else so i can trust
you to keep your word
my right hand said the other mother
holding it up she waggled the long
finger slowly displaying the claw like
nails i swear on that
coralline shrugged okay she said it's a
deal
she ate the breakfast trying not to wolf
it down she was hungrier than she had
thought
as she ate her other mother stared at
her it was hard to read expressions into
those black button eyes
but coraline thought that her other
mother looked hungry too
she drank the orange juice but even
though she knew she would like it she
could not bring herself to taste the hot
chocolate
where should i start looking asked
coraline where you wish
said her other mother as if she did not
care at all
coraline looked at her and coraline
thought hard there was no point she
decided
in exploring the garden of the grounds
they didn't exist they weren't real
there was no abandoned tennis court in
the other mother's world no bottomless
well
all that was real was the house itself
she looked around the kitchen
she opened the oven peered into the
freezer poked into the salad compartment
of the fridge
the other mother followed her about
looking at coraline with a smirk always
hovering at the edge of her lips
how big are souls anyway asked coraline
the other mother sat down at the kitchen
table and leaned back against the wall
saying nothing
she picked her teeth with a long crimson
varnish fingernail
then she tapped the finger gently tap
tap tap against the polished black
surface
of her black button eyes five squarely
don't tell me i don't care it doesn't
matter if you help me or not
everyone knows the soul is the same size
as a beach ball
she was hoping the other mother would
say something like nonsense through the
size of ripe onions or suitcases or
grandfather clocks
but the other mother simply smiled and
the tap tap tapping of her fingernail
against her eye
was as steady and relentless as the drip
of water droplets from the faucet in the
sink
and then corlin realized it was simply
the noise of the water and she was alone
in the room
coraline shivered she preferred the
other mother to have a location
if she were nowhere then she could be
anywhere and after all
it is always easier to be afraid of
something you cannot see
she put her hands into her pockets and
her fingers closed around the reassuring
shape of the stone with the hole in it
she pulled it out of her pocket held it
in front of her as if she were holding a
gun
and walked out into the hall there was
no sound but the tap tap of the water to
bring into the metal sink
she glanced at the mirror at the end of
the hall for a moment it clouded over
and it seemed to her that faces swam in
the glass indistinct and shapeless
and then the faces were gone and there
was nothing in the mirror a girl was
small for her age
holding something to glow gently like a
green coal
coraline looked down at her hand
surprised it was just a stone with a
hole in it
a non-descript brown pebble then she
looked back into the mirror where the
stone glimmered like an emerald
a trail of green fire blew from the
pebble in the mirror and drifted toward
coraline's bedroom
said coral line she walked into the
bedroom
the toys coraline looked down at her
hand surprised
it was just a stone with a hole in it a
nondescript brown pebble
then she looked back into the mirror
where the stone glimmered like an
emerald a trail of green fire blew from
the pebble in the mirror and drifted
toward coraline's bedroom
hmm she walked into the bedroom the toys
sluttered excitedly as she walked in as
if they were pleased to see her
and a little tank rolled out of the toy
box to greet her it's tread rolling over
several other toys
it fell from the toy box onto the floor
tipping as it fell and it lay on the
carpet like a beetle on its back
grumbling and grinding its treads before
coraline picked it up and turned it over
the tank fled under the bed in
embarrassment coraline looked around the
room
she looked in the cupboards in the
drawers then she picked up one end of
the toy box and tipped all the toys into
it out on the carpet
where they grumbled and stretched and
wiggled awkwardly free of each other
the gray marble rolled her flash the
floor and clicked against the wall
none of the toys looked particularly
soul-like she thought
she picked up and examined a silver
charm bracelet from which hung tiny
animal charms that chased each other
around the perimeter of the bracelet
the fox never catching the rabbit the
bear never gaining on the fox
coraline opened her hand and looked at
the stone with the hole in it hoping for
a clue
but not finding one most of the toys
that had been in the toy box
most of the toys that had been in the
toy box had now crawled away to hide
under the bed
and the few toys that were left a green
plastic soldier
the glass marble a vivid pink yo-yo and
such
were the kind of things you find in the
bottoms of toy boxes in the real world
forgotten objects abandoned and unloved
she was about to leave and look
elsewhere and then she remembered a
voice in the darkness
a gentle whispering voice and what it
had told her to do
she raised the stone with a hole in it
and held it in front of her right eye
she closed her left eye and looked at
the room through the hole in the stone
through the stone the world was grey and
colorless like a pencil drawing
everything in it was gray well not quite
everything
something glinted on the floor something
the color of an ember in a nursery
fireplace
the color of a scarlet orange tulip
nodding in the may sun
coraline reached out her left hand
scared that if she took her eye off it
it would vanish
and she fumbled for the burning thing
her fingers closed around something
smooth and cool
she snatched it up and lowered the stone
with a hole in it from her eye and
looked down
the gray glass marble from the bottom of
the toy box sat dolly
in the pink palm of her hand she raised
the stone to her eye once more and
looked at it through the marble once
again the marble
burned and flickered with a red fire
a voice whispered in her mind indeed
lady it comes to me that i certainly was
a boy
now that i do think on it oh but you
must hurry there are still two of us to
find
and the bell down was already angry with
you for uncovering me
if i'm gonna do this thought coraline
i'm not gonna do it in her clothes
she changed back into her pajamas and
her dressing gown her slippers
leaving the gray sweater and the black
jeans neatly folded up on the bed
the orange boots on the floor by the toy
box she put the marble into her dressing
gown pocket and walked out into the hall
something stung her face and hands like
sand blowing on a beach in a windy day
she covered her eyes and pushed forward
the sand stings got worse
and it got harder and harder to walk as
if you're pushing into the wind on a
particularly blustery day
it was a vicious wind and a cold one she
took a step backwards the way she had
come
oh keep going whispered a ghost voice in
her ear for the beldan was angry
she stepped forward into the hallway
into another gust of weight which stunk
her cheeks and face with invisible sand
sharp as needles sharper's glass play
fair
shuttered coraline into the wind there
was no reply but the wind whipped about
her one more time petulantly
and then it dropped away and was gone as
she passed the kitchen coral i could
hear in the sudden silence
the drip drip of the water from the
leaking tap or perhaps the other
mother's long fingernails tapping
impatiently
against the table coraline resisted the
urge to look
in a couple of strides she reached the
front door and she walked outside
coraline went down the steps around the
house until she reached the other miss
[ __ ] in miss forcible's flat
the lamps around the door were
flickering on and off almost randomly
spelling out no words the coralline
could understand the door was closed
she was afraid it was locked and she
pushed on it with all her strength
first it stuck then suddenly it gave and
with a jerk
coraline stumbled into the dark room
beyond
coraline closed one hand around the
stone with a hole in it and walked
forward into the blackness
she expected to find a curtain dancing
room but there was nothing there
the room was dark the theater was empty
she moved ahead cautiously
something rustled above her she looked
up into a deeper darkness and as she did
so her feet knocked against something
she reached down picked up a flashlight
and clicked it on sweeping the beam
around the room
the theater was derelict and abandoned
chairs were broken on the floor
and old dusty spider webs draped the
walls and hung from the rotten wood and
the decomposing velvet hangings
something rustled once again coraline
directed her light beam upward towards
the ceiling
there were things up there hairless
jelly-ish
she thought they might once who had
faces might even once even dogs
but no dogs had wings like bats or could
hang like spiders
like bats upside down the light startled
the creatures
and one of them took to the air its
wings wearing heavily through the dust
coraline ducked as it swooped close to
her it came to rest on a far wall and it
began to clamber upside down
back to the nest of the dog bats upon
the ceiling
coraline raised the stone to her eye and
she scammed the room through it looking
for something that glowed
or glinted a telltale sign that
somewhere in this room was another
hidden soul
she ran the beam of the flashlight about
the room as she searched the thick dust
in the air making the light
seem almost solid there was something up
on the back wall behind the ruins staged
it was grayish white twice the size of
coralline herself
and it was stuck to the back wall like a
slug coral in turn took a deep breath
coraline took a deep breath i'm not
afraid she told herself
i'm not she did not believe herself but
she scrambled up onto the old stage
fingers sinking into the rotting wood as
she pulled herself up
as she got closer to the thing on the
wall she saw that it was some kind of a
sack like a spider's egg case
it twitched in the light beam inside the
sack was something that looked like a
person
but a person with two heads with twice
as many arms and legs as it should have
the creature in this act seemed horribly
unformed and unfinished
as if two plasticine people had been
warmed rolled together
squashed and pressed into one thing
coraline hesitated
she did not want to approach the thing
the dog bats dropped one by one from the
ceiling
and began to circle the room coming
close to her but never touching her
perhaps there are no souls hidden in
here she thought perhaps i can just
leave and
go somewhere else she took a last look
through holmes stone
the abandoned theater was still oblique
gray but now there was a brown glow
as rich and bright as a polished cherry
wood coming from inside the sack
whatever was glowing was being held in
one of the hands of the thing on the
wall
coraline walked slowly across the damp
stage trying to make as little noise as
she could
afraid that if she disturbed the thing
in the sack it would open its eyes and
see her and then
but there was nothing she could think of
as scary as having it look at her her
heart pounded in her chest
she took another step forward she had
never been so scared but still she
walked forward until she reached the
sack
then she pushed her hand into the stinky
sticky clinging whiteness of the stuff
on the wall
it crackled softly like a tiny fire as
she pushed
and i clung to her skin and clothes like
a spider web clings
like white cotton candy she pushed her
hand into it
and she reached upward until she touched
a cold hand
which was she could feel closed around
another glass marble
the creature's skin felt slippery as if
it had been covered in jelly
coraline tugged at the marble at first
nothing happened
it was held tight in the creatures grasp
and one by one the figures loosened
their grip and the marble slipped into
her hand
she pulled her arm back through the
sticky webbing relieved that the thing's
eyes had not opened
she shown the light on its faces they
resembled she decided
the younger versions of miss pink and
miss forcible were twisted and squeezed
together
like two lumps of wax that had melted
and melded together into one ghastly
thing
without warning one of the creature's
hands made a grab for coralline's arm
its fingernail scraped her skin but it
was too slippery to grip
and coraline pulled away successfully
and then the eyes opened
four black buttons glinting and staring
down at her and two voices that sounded
like no voice that cornline had ever
heard
began to speak to her one of them wailed
and whispered
the other buzzed like a fat and angry
blue bottle at a window pane but the
voices said as one person
thief give it back stop thief
the air became alive with dog bats
coraline began to back away
she realized then that terrifyingly the
thing on the wall that had once been the
other mrs think enforceable was
it was attached to the wall by its web
encased in its cocoon it could not
follow her
the dog bats flapped and fluttered about
her but they did nothing to hurt carline
she climbed down from the stage shown
the flashlight about the old theater
looking for the way out flea miss wilder
girls voice in her head flee now
you have two of us flee this place while
your blood still flows
coraline dropped marble into her pocket
beside the other she spotted the door
ran to it and pulled on it until it
opened
[Music]
you